Elizabeth
hersley will come in yes that's why I'm
showing a party
welcome to Elizabeth pets she just won a
beautiful game against gunai
muhammadzada Elizabeth well tell us a
little bit more about this game it was
quite a complicated one and you found a
beautiful idea later in the game so so
actually like Bishop B7 was the first
move which was kind of surprising she
had a game with H6 actually enough the
H6 the main move is Bishop H4 but
there's also Bishop takes F6 which leads
to something crazy but if black knows it
well then it's nothing for White and the
funny part is like from the psychology
point of view she had a game instead of
Bishop B7 she had a game with H6
and after Bishop takes F6 uh take on F6
with Bishop
H4
I think B4 and according to the engine
it's better for black she lost this game
because of one tiny mistake which
happened later
but the funny part is like that somehow
she was yet scared even though so light
is nothing for white social you analyzed
it precisely no this line I analyzed I
wouldn't have played like this because I
know that this line gives nothing and I
was sure that after she lost to Bull
mugger she would have improved on that
but somehow like she was thinking for 20
minutes and moved bishop p7 and now I
was passing before to do because I
didn't know what to do in fact because
um there is some line instead of Bishop
instead of Rook B8 that played Bishop B7
instantly and now I choose F5 but the
point about F5 here is that for example
like after E5 what she played in the
game this is normal Bishop takes F6 I
think according to my knowledge Bishop
takes F6 is the strongest move and here
the problem is like now that actually
like she has the tempo
um I have a temple office Bishop G2 in
fact because there is this position with
Rook A8 and Bishop F1 but the point is
that the bishop on G2 happens to be
worse on G2 then on F1 because now if I
go Knight F3 which is one of the
engine's moves but not here in a
different line then after Knight P6
Knight C4 it's not convenient so here
actually I have to go Knight B3
so likely I understood that uh
um well it gives nothing so I mean I'm
sure that after Bishop B7 F5 is somehow
wrong but the other line which I checked
instead of F5
what was interesting
um is to play H4 here so basically to
convince her that after age six Bishop
takes F6 Bishop takes F6 instead of you
know instead of Bishop B7 then B4 was
the best move but now she already moved
Bishop B7 and I was thinking maybe I can
improve that but the problem is like if
I play G5 here I thought she takes on D4
and then plays E5
and I was not sure about that
even though the computer I see likes it
but I still was not sure about that so
this was the second option I saw but
there were a lot of complications yes
were you surprised by this decision well
no because I had a similar game against
her like many years ago in 2017 where
she also like in the same line tend to
take with a Pawn on F6 so she kind of
likes that
and I had a similar position with black
against bull marker as well where I was
totally lost in the Grand Prix I managed
to win this game with Mario so I thought
like okay this position is easier to
play for white it's okay so what was the
next critical moment I think the most
critical moment is a move 21 okay let's
have a look when she played H5
and after age five I mean like I wasn't
sure like I mean the thing is like she
lost a little bit the crib because she
lost the in the moment when she
played Knight c492 Knight B6 actually
because maybe she was hoping for a draw
but somehow I sensed in this moment that
she didn't know what to do
so I played Rook C1 in order to
prophylactically protect and after H5 I
was also not sure what to do I played G5
which is also the best move according to
the engine she took on G5 and I took on
H5 so I played well I see so good
and here I thought she should go
um not Bishop F6 but maybe she should
just go Um
G4 yes it was uh well it's suggestion by
the computer before then I play F6 no I
F6 I would have played no maybe she
should take on H4 actually because if
you're like tactically like worse you
should craft the material then you play
F6 and they always have six so she
played F6 Bishop F6 herself which I
think was still probably the best move
practically speaking
and now I didn't know what to do I
played group G1 and I couldn't decide
whether I go Rook G3 or Rook G1 but did
you find this idea uh beforehand when
you did you think that after Rook G1 if
she plays King seven you already had
this idea
so many times already but I didn't have
and when she played King E7 I uh I then
I understood something like Bishop F7
and immediately took on G5 so this was
obviously like the main blunder
and the funny part is like that after
Bishop takes F7 the most critical line
is Bishop takes D2 I was calculating F6
and I was calculating Bishop E6 and the
game I would have played Bishop E6
because I'm like too lazy to calculate
too much and I was sure this was a nice
move of course but Bishop B6 is winning
the computer says that after this uh a
black is hopeless here but of course
it's it's not obvious because this was
not I saw this line as well but I
wouldn't have played it I would have
played Bishop E6 here because just by
intuition
Bishop E6 and I think here
um for example like if she takes one C3
I have something like Queen G2 Rook
she's three something like that and I
was sure I was winning
so I didn't even know what she would do
here after Queen G4 yes sure I mean look
she's three crunchy for something but
something like on the cheaper okay so
and let's get back to to the end of the
game I think that it was rather hopeless
after yes maybe I could have wanted
quicker but somehow I wanted to play it
safe after yesterday
so I just think like uh ka5 here you can
do anything and she resigned but uh many
options here Elizabeth uh well that was
a fine game I think from many points
well everyone knows that you're sending
me the messages at five in the morning
so everyone hopes that you're going to
sleep better uh tell me so what do you
do then after no I have a great morning
because I wake up at five and I'm
totally awake so it's the most funny
part okay it's obviously jet lag but on
the other hand like I fall asleep at
nine o'clock so I think it's uh it's
very fine but at five o'clock I'm
reading for one hour then at like 6 30 I
get impatience where I wake up my
boyfriend then at seven o'clock I take a
coffee and then at eight o'clock I go to
swim for one hour because at nine
o'clock already a lot of kids are coming
so you don't have your piece and then
actually around 9 9 30 I slowly start to
prepare so how important it is to
include the physical preparation into
your daily routine
um usually like you know
um I'm not doing sports during the
tournament but the pool is so nicely
heated that I can't resist to use a
chance and I don't think that swimming
takes too much of my energy because I'm
not screaming like a athlete or like a
wool Champion I'm swimming like a calm
old little fashion girl so
um I would call the grand mom styles
kind of swimming obviously so yes and
after the swimming actually like uh yeah
I'll I would usually prepare if I mean
today I prepared at like six o'clock a
little bit and then maybe at nine
o'clock but anyway
um it didn't happen on the board what I
was expecting thank a bit uh yes sir
Nazi do you have a question uh just our
congratulations Elizabeth a very very
fine game indeed and we thought you were
just playing a really great game a
beautiful game yeah yeah keep it up
compliments compliments and uh